voltz bird vs Schalke but not as we know
it in a fan zone bivalves burg stadium
the club's eSports teams will battle it
out on FIFA 17 to see who his top of the
virtual league complete with commentary
shall cos defense looking good a
through-ball of the post the players
remain in passive but volts burger in
the ascendancy another cross there's a
goal 1 millivolt bugs team will seep and
that's how it's finished I was
definitely cool everyone celebrated at
one nil I had a great time they had a
great time that's what FIFA does it
creates a connection to football the
competition is designed to bridge the
gap between the online gaming world and
real fans and it's working kind of a
fitness hopefully you I think it's good
for young people but I didn't have a
clue what was going on and how it works
it's not for me you celebrate when a
goal is scored and there's lots of
emotion involved just like in real life
and I think that's why people will like
it right off control yeah of course it
can be part of the football club but
reality is something else entirely
that's what appeals to the masses but
virtual football seems destined to grow
clubs like Bayern Munich and Borussia
mönchengladbach are apparently planning
their own a sports teams with a view to
competing eventually in a virtual
Bundesliga a dream is this there are
currently two Bundesliga teams that have
a gamer under contract in one or two
years I think there'll be 10 11 or 12
and then you can set up some tournaments
unlike real life footballers team was
even as schalke counterpart don't earn
enough to live off yet but the eSport is
becoming ever more liquor ative
especially now it has caught the
attention of the Bundesliga giants